nous sommes sur l'appellation des
coteaux du giennois 4 hectares et demi
de sauvignon blanc s'épanouissent ici
cette ligne est issu de vignes du centre
val de loire qui pour certaines ont plus
d'une centaine d'années c'est une
sélection massale exactement c'est des
pieds qui ont été sélectionnés il ya
maintenant une vingtaine d'années par ci
cavac et que on a planté en 2015 afin de
les produire et de les multiplier via
des pépiniéristes partenaires voilà dans
le but 2 2
préserver une diversité génétique qui
est de moins en moins présente dans nos
vignobles les vignerons sont persuadés
que ce cépage de sauvignon blanc qui a
fait ses preuves de longévité donnera à
terme des plans de vignes plus durable
et de très haute qualité olivier l'unio
viticulteur à menetou salon on a planté
sept mille pieds sur son domaine on est
convaincu c'est vrai que ces sections la
salle sont issus d'un projet collectif
qui émane du centre loire c'est 6
environ il ya vraiment un gros travail
de recherche est d'amener ses diversités
où vous voulez au delà de la conserver
dans un dans un lieu on voulait vraiment
qu'elle se diffusant le vignoble donc
que nous sommes les premiers acteurs
pour sauver cette biodiversité et
j'encourage - tous les vignerons à
réfléchir à implanter ccc ces pieds de
vigne parce que ils sont l'avenir sur
cette parcelle expérimentale les
vignerons cherche aussi à élaborer un
cépage pauvre en sucre pour limiter le
degré d'alcool et on a pas mal de
l'année solaire par évidemment cette
année c'est différent mais de toute
façon y'a qu'à prendre la date des
vendanges on voit que depuis depuis 20
ans assez considérablement avancé ce qui
fait que les vins sont aussi plus plus
fort plus riches en sucre donc plus fort
en alcool
prochaine étape des recherches la
plantation de cépages résistants à
l'oïdium et le mildiou